un referéndum de iniciativa compartida
Es una herramienta que tiene la
Constitución Francesa para someter a
plebiscito una iniciativa de ley que
tenga que ver con alguna reforma de las
políticas sociales económicas o
medioambientales de esa herramienta se
aprovecharon un grupo de parlamentarios
opositores en marzo pasado para
presentar una iniciativa para que la
edad de jubilación no fuera más allá de
los 62 años sin embargo el consejo
constitucional Consideró que esta
iniciativa era inconstitucional
justamente porque no presentaba ninguna
reforma Ya que en el momento de ser
presentada la de jubilación todavía era
de 62 años en ese momento y antes de que
la ley de reforma de la jubilaciones
fuera promulgada otro grupo de
parlamentarios de izquierda presentó una
nueva iniciativa con el mismo título y
el mismo primer artículo de la primera
iniciativa pero sumando un segundo
artículo que prevé que hay un aumento en
los impuestos del capital que vaya
directamente al apartado vejez de la
seguridad social efectivamente había una
reforma dice lo constitucionalistas pero
era muy poco probable que el consejo
constitucional aprobara una iniciativa
en su conjunto cuando los artículos ya
había sido declarado
anticonstitucional también dicen otros
que aún cuando el consejo constitucional
aprobara esa iniciativa iba a ser muy
difícil que se concretara ya que
necesitaba reunir en nueve meses el
apoyo de cuatro coma ocho millones de
franceses que es un 10% del electorado y
tampoco ser tramitada ni por los
diputados ni por los senadores para que
fuera directamente al presidente para
probar lo difícil que es que un
referéndum de iniciativa compartida sea
aprobado en Francia nunca una iniciativa
de este tipo prosperado desde el año
2008 desde que existe justamente esta
herramienta en la constitución